[Musique]
hong kong
c'est un labyrinthe de palétuviers entre
terre et mer la mangrove se découvre
lentement au fil de l'eau et de ses
méandres frangé de lianes et de racines
aériennes
nous sommes dans l'unique par parent de
rdc une forêt de 25 mille hectares à
l'embouchure du fleuve congo thomas mme
fu on connaît tous les secrets c'est une
forêt des transitions entre les milieux
aquatiques et les milieux terrestres y
relie les deux milliers ils protègent la
côte contre
les érosions
si tadic
il consulte tu es rend pas
important
les changements climatiques le parc a
été créé en 1992 et a été désigné site
ramsar c'est-à-dire zones humides
d'importance internationale en 1996
le site est aujourd'hui protégé seuls
quelques dizaines de pêcheurs sont
autorisés à y vivre il habite ici depuis
plusieurs générations
blanchard plonge en apnée chaque jour
pour ramasser des huîtres d'eau douce
l'ebit boîte 6
quand tu pars chercher les coquillages
au fond c'est ton souffle qui va
déterminer ce que tu va ramener si tu
n'as pas à cette souffle tu va nous
ramener qu'une seule à la fois mais
alors tu devras faire beaucoup de
plongée pour en ramasser suffisamment
après la pêche blanchard retourne sur
son île de key zoom gamme à l'ailé on
l'appelle l'île aux coquillages car elle
est entièrement recouverte de coquilles
d'huîtres
ses habitants et vivent sans électricité
presque sans réseau téléphonique comme
coupés du monde la joie que nous avons
de vivre ici c'est d'être entouré de
toute cette nature juste au bord de
l'eau on y trouve de quoi manger et ce
sont de très bonne source de protéines
bissau les branches des arbres me permet
aussi de construire nos maisons et
d'allumer le feu
un mode de vie respectueux de
l'environnement dans un écosystème d'une
richesse exceptionnelle
de nombreuses espèces menacées y ont élu
domicile comme les tortues olivâtres qui
se donne rendez vous chaque année pour
pondre sur les plages
nombre de nids
pour les protéger les agents du parc des
places les nids dans cet enclos et les
surveille jusqu'à l'éclosion des les
prédateurs ont laissé le ghana tire ya
le club qui dérange et aller les combos
qui dérange la population même mangé la
viande et autres tortues c'est pourquoi
on a peur parce que même la population
elle même qu'elle vienne voilée n'y
paraît c'est l'heure pour les bébés nés
ce matin-là de rejoindre l'océan
atlantique
christian aura veiller sur eux pendant
50 jours mais il sait qu il les reverra
bientôt
après sept ans elles vont garder elle
doit revenir encore ici là où l'a fait
mais l'aîné c'est là où elle doit
devenir à comprendre les et
qu'elle se souvient
d'elle
plus de 80 mille bébés tortues ont déjà
été relâchées en dix ans une victoire
pour les éco gardes du parc ils sont
quinze à surveiller ce joyau naturel
avec un budget annuel de moins de cent
mille dollars chaque jour en bateau ou à
pied ils patrouillent la forêt pour
veiller sur la faune et la flore
toujours l'antilope se veulent
comme s'ils avaient des et à une autre
etc est passé de l'autre côté
ce jour là la patrouille tombe sur un
four à charbon artisanales fabriquées
par des villageois la coupe de bois
illégal est l'une des principales
menaces pour la mangrove et le phénomène
est accentué par la croissance
démographique
à chaque fois on vient on organise des
patrouilles pour détruire tous hélas
pour les décourager mais il ya deux
traits qui continue toujours à les faire
alors il ya deux traits qui poussent des
régions n'a pas de travail qu'est ce
qu'on va faire si la région est riche de
sa biodiversité la population locale vit
dans une extrême pauvreté ni le tourisme
ni même l'exploitation du pétrole au
large non profiter aux habitants de la
région alors si la construction d'un
port en eau profonde à banana à 500
mètres à peine de la mangrove inquiète
certains scientifiques la société civile
locale se montre plus nuancé nous allons
surveiller
d'abord les ports soient construits à la
limite comme prévu dans les cahiers des
charges veiller que l'écosystème ne soit
pas affectée par les gros bateaux notre
position est claire c'est soutenir un
projet qui va nous amener et un
développement selon le gouvernement
congolais le projet n'aura pas
d'incidence majeure sur la mangrove et
permettra la création de lle d'emplois à
ce jour aucune étude d'impact
environnemental n'a été rendu public
[Musique]